yeah I mean what I actually said is that
not that it didn't have an impact on the
extremely look because obviously it does
and it did but that it shouldn't because
the actions whether you agree with them
or not were not referable to religion
and I think in relation to this
extremism I mean the basic point that I
was making my speech is that there is a
narrative about this extremism that has
to be taken on defeated because the
narrative is a far wider adherent than
the extremism and that actually you know
whether we agree with Western policy or
not is one issue but I I mean personally
brown as a matter of judgment political
judgment will reject the idea that the
West is actually hostile to Islam and
and I think it's only if you reject that
idea that you start to defeat the
extremism now some people profoundly
disagree with that and say you know the
West is or the Westers created this
situation but I think that's the debate
you've got to have really politically
and you know you see I I mean I came to
conclusion politically through long
experience politics that sometimes
though there's a natural tendency when
you want to do to persuade people to
change their behavior to kind of meet
them halfway you know so you could say
yeah okay I are agree that we've done
some very terrible things but
nonetheless let's reconcile together and
by meeting people halfway you open the
door to the reconciliation that's a
perfectly you know I totally get that as
a concept you know that makes a lot of
sense it except that in this particular
instance I think what you do
is you distort and deform the whole
basis of the conversation because
actually when you then start to analyze
what are the terrible things that you've
done it actually then becomes quite hard
to because you know if you look back
they say pre 911 what is the thing that
meant that you know that anyone could
think of a justification for that see
what I mean so that actually what you do
my this is my view but it is a political
debate is that by meeting halfway in
this argument what you actually do is
disempower the moderates and sensible
people from within Islam who would say
actually we've got to handle this issue
ourselves and sort it out and not think
that it's been created from outside our
religion by something the Westers doing
to us so that's what I think the issues
but it's you know this is it maybe spend
the whole seminar on that one